all right and I'm live in flashpoint is
back Bartus I missed you man
well welcome back sir let's go yeah we
are good to be back have a good trip in
the shaft but uh missed out on the
flashpoint unfortunately I know you held
it down a lot of stuff going on a
destiny where I'm at what's going on
with you I probably talked way too long
last my random tangents all on my own it
was like weird I was a sorry for those
who actually had to sit there no it was
it was good just kind of one of those
times where I kind of went off on armor
a little bit more just because you know
I let loose a little bit and just a
couple pieces about you know exotics
come in and stuff so my biggest thing
that I probably wrapped up on the end
was like September's one gap that I
haven't seen much on is the changes to
armor so come on we'll get there in a
second about this morning flashpoint aka
Long Point join June 1st June 1st this
is kind of nuts yeah but yeah we got a
new patch came out one point two point
one we got it this week at Bungie that
blew most of our socks off and tidbits
and changes throughout the week as well
so without any further ado you want to
start with some patch notes just so you
can cover general general changes here
let me pull them actually didn't mean
pull pull the bad boys up gonna bulldoze
it right there on the world patching
one point two point one launched on May
29th and we had a few a few changes yep
we're basically very settled because
working to get information like drip fed
to us apparently they said hey vection
irelia's changes I was like wonderful
just gonna tap my fingers until today
until yesterday and afternoon so now we
know what's with faction early so we'll
get to that in a second once you get to
this week at Bungie sandbox we had the
exotic armor yes so let's get started
with actual information there we go yeah
the I was in I can't even ounce to
mekinese trick sleeves yep
um critically wounded you swap to the
sidearm got the damage buff two times in
PVE 1.33 exile of those rare unique
numbers that gonna jump out of that one
no the Warlocks I definitely think got
the big rating this year so that he had
a dragon shadow that exotic at the
Dodger those are weapons simultaneously
dodging now also grants the +5 mobility
for the duration of the race neat metal
male in addition to its previous
benefits and then you got a UI indicator
for that buff so have you tried those
too
yeah like on PC I need their time still
how don't have a hunter so I know flash
point those out then the the tight you
got the lion rampant the hipfiring no
longer interrupts lift increase hipfire
accuracy while airborne man I would love
that for a dawn blade oh I've heard that
one and then some and then pairing it
actually with sky burners oath when you
go basically I think it was Mesa Shan or
something just basically think of an
ac-130 around think about that that's
that's a great combo with sky but
especially with the new buffs Cabernets
got with the just shooting it off off
the hip and it has almost like a grenade
launcher effective little mini grenade
tracking you know that one's actually
cool one so I mean that's one of the
first actual mini builds and that's
forget the video so I don't knows Mesa
or fallout I probably watched both of
you guys this week but I was weaned you
too yeah that's one that's actually like
a little mini build yeah that's a nice
little build right there I like that no
that's something you got to set this up
they got the flat melee damage bonus for
eight seconds when you're surrounded by
three or more enemies three times in PvE
to 1080p the buffs also increased super
damage while active have you even seen
that nation' or well I saw somebody
testing this one saying hey this is
broken and they basically had three
people stand in a bubble
the free enemies like on a private match
punch and they get actually to shot them
oh wow
now the other piece that somebody
commented below is like how often is
that ever gonna go in yeah so I was like
I don't and this is one for me it's like
okay so if I'm surrounded by enemies
mm-hmm three more more enemies for eight
seconds I'm like okay now the fact that
the buff increases super damage while
active that I'm kind of curious on do I
have to punch something or I mean do I
have to be surrounded like do surround
myself by thralls then do I chunk a
hammer over at a boss and do a question
it's like it's kind of a we it it's a
very very weirdly situational it's like
I don't want to be surrounded by three
enemies that seems like a terrible way
just a bad place above which so again
this is one for me that I don't think
quite hits it right it's like an
understand they're going for a concept
of London after I just don't think the
ones where you have to be surrounded by
three enemies where you have to die
those like tough situations yeah I'm
just yeah it's not something I want to
waste in exotic on to see if I'm the
only one that I must admit that I do
like as the warlock I forgot it's a
chess piece I forget the name the Vesper
yeah I will admit that it's it's useful
at times because um when you're doing
hard content and it's you know two or
three guys see in that case you know you
don't have to you don't have to get hit
or you know I'm saying like but it's
just more so like the enemies around you
then you get the rift right back you
know you're recharging reference right
back so I get that but it's like with
this intercepts it's like yeah I kind of
don't I can't understand when you come
from from a Titan perspective you know
fun class since forget yeah it's the
real fun which I actually lost oh yeah
so I've tested one I would tested the
other Luna faction boots I did not test
did you yes I did so I'll let you take
this one i'ma tell you right now it's
fantastic
um because as a warlock I've always been
jealous of the Titan rally barricade
mm-hmm and all I can think of is doing
cosplay
jump
from plate to plate and those guys you
know you just duck and you're getting on
like damn that's a great you know perk
so with the Luna factions now what's
doable body is you just literally just
stay in the rift and you're shooting
like that you know what you realize how
great it is is you have like sins the
path of the path scuse me and you're
shooting um we say you're on a patrol
and you know you doing one of the UH the
what you call it's you know you're
helping out there why am i blanking on
the name I know those things I miss a
week and I forget what nasty things are
called so you doing a public event
nobody's rock your slow reload click
click no you just bang bang bang bang
now which is dope is that you are now
encouraged to use empowering wrists yes
you know they're and it's just it's such
a great team buff the Luna faction boots
have really elevated for single boss DPS
oh yeah it is it is fantastic so now
it's like I can't wait to do Leviathan
right now so I want to do cabbage but
you're just want to melt stuff and then
what I'm already already what I'm right
now I'm working on is a mod cuz I want
to take the default ma that's in the
lunar faction boots and I want to put
those towards rift energy rift energy
recovery so I have a bill that I'm just
getting the rift all the time he's gonna
fight a boss in power let's go fantastic
and some people with cirrhosis where it
spins up you end up as you holding it
it's just like it's oh yeah I've seen
some fun and these these this is
something that it's like yeah this feels
exotic as opposed to census EPS no not
to me and again it's the when you have
this much of a disparity you're talking
about it this huge this big I'm like
yeah I don't feel the same way about the
others now lion rampart it's you know it
is kind of a thing for morgan pvp and
moving and shooting oil while in the air
and actually no hip fight increased
hipfire accuracy while airport that's
like i mean miss five thousand watts
rubber
that was like whoo yeah but that's the
type of stuff so it's like not Luna
faction boots I've seen too many videos
about all right that's kind of a good
way to know if you see a lot of videos
about something that probably give you
any idea that it's probably pretty good
absolutely Sun bracers not too shabby
now again a little bit situational yes
for one solar melee
solar melee kills how's grant unlimited
solar grenade energy for a short
duration so if you can know this is one
where it's situational but the benefit I
think outweighs something like cyntha
seps so if there's a month if there's an
ad and I punch it and I kill it and
there's a major nearby I'm just gonna
cook like five grenades on his head just
throw there like throw it screw that as
long as the animation takes you get
about four or five of them out there
mmm-hmm and then the fact the solar
grenades last forever so yes they just
sit there and cook yeah they really good
effect
yeah so pretty cool one and you like
solar grenade or if you like solar at
all it's just a fun one to run around
with absolutely you got a couple other
changes random perk was changed exotic
they fix the sound things arose could
not reload well I do so couple random
things
Multi middle multi-tool domestic
catalysts can now be obtained by the
most determined competitors and crucible
so I guess they added that in so
crucible labs they said they're going to
talk about later we'll get to a
discussion on that here and a little bit
they had some the big one that I talked
about last week
Exodus crash was removed from heroic but
they still left it normal touch that
playlist it's mhm so yeah heroic strikes
now have a chin a 25% roughly 25% chance
to reward powerful engrams up to 360 now
that is somewhat noticeable but I've
also seen people on Twitter saying I've
done like seven strikes and haven't got
anything yet oh wow so I don't know how
that's calculated takes me getting a
four I could do full like strikes and
not have that work so it's not like it's
keeping track so I've heard not quite
the best on that one
but other than that pretty basic normal
Corrections things like that they
mentioned all that stuff is in there so
not too much on that one so let us go
over to this week at Bungie because
there's that first right here hats off
our team because first we got faction
rallies now so there's a little picture
below I'm gonna try not to scroll down
any farther but I just want to talk
about this picture just at first we
complained about the art and yes like
what do you want out of your faction
rallies what do you want it to look like
when you see something more this is a
start this is a step in that direction
you've got dead orbit with this like
snake wrapped around the middle logo and
then you've got this like there's more
to this picture up here factional future
war cult it's probably still gonna be
tame I love the ornate nasaan new
monarchy to us at least I got to I'm on
board with feature wall card it's just
future it fits it's kind of yeah there
so but I just like the fact that they
even flat-out change the banners the
logos everything they like cables gonna
make it better so art was step one so
cool very cool now we'll get the faction
elders in a second because we've got
something a little bigger to talk about
BAM let's go
okay so they said the development
roadmap has some new milestones some
will say yet to be revealed and they say
that time has come which is Tuesday so
heads up we gonna do a impromptu yeah
year to reveal oh boy it's gonna be
Tuesday afternoon/evening whenever sleep
and giving off work happens it's gonna
be Tuesday though so we got an extra
flashpoint because you're gonna be out
of town for e3 and I'm gonna be working
sell your to reveal come and first take
a look at this picture what are you
thinking reef baby see see it in the
back and uh you know again I'm actually
surprised what I'll just wanted before
we get into speculation I'm actually
very surprised but it's because my
feeling was I figured they would do
didn't use I don't know what do you what
would you think I didn't I didn't think
we would get a reveal so quick it kind
of threw me off I was like I mean I'm
happy don't even I'm not out of
disappointed I'm very
I'm just like wow already I figured
maybe maybe I'm forgetting like when
last year's e3 came around and let's say
let's say what was that forward it
wasn't um well what destiny probably was
now is for destiny itself right that's a
good point I gotta go do the history on
that because I'm just trying to remember
see the timing of it did we get to
reveal maybe we did get to reveal prior
to e3 real event it's just too uh so
here's an article saying it doesn't be
from a second destiny two's reveal event
in just over two weeks away will give us
a look at the PC version so it was in
May so is in May okay but that was like
a new game right so I get it but I was
still just slightly pre e3 this is yeah
I guess they're doing the same thing
they're just getting their coverage out
there before e3 because I guess there's
always the thing everybody worries about
getting it lots of shuffle yeah I mean
destiny is big enough it's gonna have
some things but you have so many large
things out there and even fertilization
which is probably where they're gonna be
involved they have their big four and
weak yes didn't have a little taint
about e3 if we got time but they I mean
they know their twitch streams they know
those work well so this is what they're
gonna do and do it before him and I
think it's a great job I think it's um
you get that height going you've got a
little goodwill going to after woman you
know obviously is not a perfect
expansion but um you know you got some
positive vibes in the right direction
and now you get this going you get the
height train going you know we seen that
it looks like the reef in the back
we know the speculation going on about
you know the Queen and hard not being
dead and the brotherbrother there's a
whole bunch of Easter eggs or Mars
they've been kind of hitting in that
direction as well as the Telesto
ornament it has something like reef in
ruin so the question for me is like what
the hell are we gonna be doing
yeah that's like the big idea I mean you
had the reef isn't quite where because
we saw the rings of Saturn are pretty
messed up from that big blast from worx
ship but he's not that close to the rent
to the reef or that got messed up
but yeah it's like what happened to reef
what happened to the brother is the
Queen issues I mean there's a lot of
this is one of those especially for the
people at myelin games and by if this is
the one where the story if they screw
this up it's like you can't keep
screwing up the story because as we've
been like tiptoeing around all of this
stuff in the reef we introduce
characters in d1 we had major events
happen to those characters in d1 we have
questions about people that we got to
see more than the stranger for two
seconds so we have some investment as a
social space in the reef and then we're
gonna go back like we we want I want
some little do you want a little more
depth I just want a little like take
take what we take a taking King level of
story to it I want I want that so I mean
it's here too it's gonna be a full comet
expansion if you guys don't know what I
mean by comment it's basically their key
word code word whatever they use in
house for the major like year to chunk
same way taking King was it was it was a
pretty pretty big revamp of it was the
cuesta fication of destiny I remember
that word flying around it
oh yeah but I mean taking king it was
like it was a full eight story missions
I think it was eight right yeah so I
mean it was eight but they were pretty
lengthy you were walking around the full
dreadknot so I mean it was bigger so
this has got to be large but here's the
thing the reef was a social space yes
you can read the picture you don't look
like there's enough place to explore a
per se so where else do you think we're
going this is gonna be interesting I
mean they may pull they may pull up
morons right because when we went back
to Mars we didn't go exactly to where we
were in d1 right they had us in the
specific area Hellas Basin or whatever
mm-hmm and um you know they may do that
the only thing is the weep itself is
strange by nature because it's kind of
like you know it's kind of like a whole
bunch of floating asteroid back you know
whatever's out there planet and then
also what I was thinking about
is armed prison of elders warehouse and
let's just let's just call it what it is
this gotta be the fallen this has to be
the fallen that's what yeah it's a lot
of people are like theorizing and that's
just the main faction here like fallen
is the big people who briefed was like
fighting with I mean we had prison of
elders for that exact reason dealing
with the fallen so gotta find out what's
going on with verax because we've had
history with him and and he's left if
you if you're on the European dead zone
he's left his little signal that little
symbol that he has around there this
there's a lot of Easter eggs about him
and what's going on with the different
houses so we got to see he's on our side
what's going on dad we gotta say that to
find out to fail obviously of the the
Queen which we pretty much confirmed it
she's around the brother what's going on
him you know what space specifically and
then I know this is a long shot and it's
probably not gonna happen but there was
a lot of Osiris tied to the reef you
know I mean so yeah we had the whole
tribe that's where it all came from the
social space so his trials of I mean the
roles of the nine travel be interesting
it would be interesting to see III know
it's a long shot I doubt you know we
bring Osiris in in any capacity you know
but it is interesting because during his
the courser Osiris DLC one of his in a
whole storyline is to prevent this
future of the reef being destroyed you
know just be weird but maybe they don't
put it in because it's fallen and stuff
so Lucy no I mean there's a lot there so
I mean in September even on the roadmap
as it says right now we've got it's the
big stuff we're talking about some kind
of curious how much they're gonna reveal
how much they're gonna hold back because
III I think a lot of people see it like
speculation or whatever that game the
new gameplay mode the one that people
did not want to put down at that it's
coming I mean that was potentially gonna
be on stage somewhat if they do or a
reveal and talked about this thing it's
gonna be it's gonna be huge so you got
weapon randomization of some level shape
fashion of mobs or who knows what so
we'll see weapons slot changes that's
good
sure if that's just gonna be you've got
kinetic energy
and special people just gonna lose
however that goes that'll be interesting
records is probably gonna be just like
record books we had before gear
collections I still don't know what that
means is that just like your I mean the
collections we have now or just like
your collections of exotics collections
of other stuff like being as you have
weapon randomization and collections I'm
confused
so I don't know thing but what here
we'll keep it somewhat simple because
we've had a lot of things we want we
know they've been a lot of changes we've
got some more stuff coming what is one
thing for fall what's your what's your
must for fall what's your one Wow one or
give me a couple I'm just you know
you're trying to keep it something I
dunno we like 50 by like 10 I know
everybody wants I guess for me I'm not
as gung-ho crazy listen when if they
said they're gonna change weapon slots
and that's fine you know they can do
that like I'm not I'm actually more
about the weapon randomization the park
randomization random roles
I need that that was part of the chase I
missed that you know I miss people yeah
and what what it would really is gonna
separate it is because with the
duplicates you know what I have you know
when I have that better devils and it's
just the same thing I need a different
better Devils I need a different so now
I can use archetypes that got potential
with just different better perks you
know so that is better Devils cuz I got
like five of them recently yeah it's
like I don't know why it's like I didn't
get that many up until this expansion
and then I got like three in a row
mmm-hmm sorry so it's like you got that
I think um man I noticed I don't think
it's a big crazy ask but you dope if we
got a new subclass man oh it would be
kinda like you really would change again
you'd get people excited to play a new
subclass for your character
if they don't do sub-clan what if they
just what if there was a fourth I know
I'm reaching now I don't know what I
mean that's those are so those are major
things that will get people to be like
okay I'm gonna make a new character cuz
this is gonna change the balance the
game this is how you're gonna put
together your fire teams your raid
parties this is like that would be major
that's mmm I like I like one or I like
either and I think honestly to get some
people who've really left the train back
it might take something that big and
that may large it in charge mm-hmm all
right so no that's - what's your third
stealing some pretty major roads coke
overly to chase it to do subclass the
darkness like a rigged way from Lord of
the Rings just all fear like shadow and
evil the third one's gotta be I want a
clear and concise raid so I can get my
boy addict back you know I need I need
that man I need oh I don't I think
they're gonna double down and still give
us a rain layer from what my gut tells
me that they really hope not I hope know
what you're saying
hazing five flats with me are the dark
oh I need that concise taken King like
experience where we have like eight to
ten you know missions explaining what
the threat is what's going on in the
reef yadda yadda yadda then boom we get
to the final thing we beat it we realize
okay you know we beaten completed the
story
we stopped something you know kind of
major from happening but there's an
overarching thing that now we have to
really take care of in the raid and it
needs to be its own place Leviathan
needs to be you know it's blown up now I
don't want to hear anything will arrived
and now yeah that's gonna mess piss
people off I want that that what that
narrative cinematic explaining why
we're going in what's going on the
threat and if you know K now it needs to
be tied in you know aesthetically it
can't be just some random thing that has
that doesn't seem to be they had to have
that disconnect doesn't seem to be
associated so those are three perk
random perk roles um new subclass /
careless yeah no and um the third would
be raid layer continuity
those are my ones you're up like alright
for me
armor has to matter that's one of my big
ones and that's what I was talking about
last week I need to armor perks that
come back I want like sets to actually
go in and wire I want like a European
set that works towards you know so I can
take on the Fallen I want a Titan set
that works towards the hive I once I
mean those types of pieces that make the
gear matter and then random roles within
those as well so let if you say you get
like set pieces you're like hey this
one's not quite right but no I can go
so I mean armor for me has to matter as
I was talking to you you have 5/8 of
your inventory that actually matters I
mean Cosmetics outside 5/8 of it you
have three weapons maybe four maybe
three changing stuff up I want armor to
matter I want armor perks to be like hey
you have more power weapon ammo hey you
get orbs they come an orb you get health
back okay like grenade throw distance
but I was like go even deeper into it go
farther with all that stuff give me some
stuff that matters so my armor has to
matter that's nice because you saying it
because I thought I was the armor guy
like I didn't realize how important not
you know like well that's I mean it's I
didn't realize as much until I got taken
and that's one of those it's like I
always thought about the perks and it
was like I was never like quite on the
min/max thing I tried to work towards
tier 12 I never you know don't know
never quite got there but I was in that
tier 12 grind that was a huge deal in
tier and not easily I was like that
stuff in there mattering and gave you
something to shoot for be like I was
checking the stats at the vendor is like
the
what were those things called and do you
want artifacts artifacts yes those
things with those big stat rules
especially when they'd like you know
sometimes they'd help two or three or
this thing has like a hundred points to
a stand or something insane and it was
just like what has had like those types
of things so yeah armor has to matter in
lots of ways
give me some armor sets give me red
perks that actually met yeah give me red
perks that set it on top yeah good stuff
yeah DJ sing in your chat saying just a
Theon raid weapons of Gears yeah exactly
so rewards are big too and kind of
tapping on to your connection of the
raid
I want the pieces of the game and this
is what I don't know if it's a d3 ask
some of these is a little bigger I would
like the pieces of the game to connect
to each other yes so if I go through the
story and don't have me fight the raid
boss at the end of the story let's start
with that okay okay so don't have me
fight a worm God in mission four of the
story and then I just took out a worm
yeah
like there's only five of those in the
universe and they've been around and are
a hell of a lot older than Oryx and all
his brothers and sisters and sons like
come on like step it up no I want to go
through a story and this is hey this is
your reveal this is your introduction
and be like just like the end of a
Marvel movie Thanos will return just
like the end of a in the in this game be
like yeah whatever boss this is we'll
return in the raid give me incentive to
step to that next level I want to see I
want to see those pieces of connection
then also give me a reason to go run a
strike and let me pick the damn strike I
want to run please put a mine map
there's not that many of them just let
me pick a difficulty or something like
that that's fine but and but I would I
also want us they did it before actually
in d1 better than almost in d2 you'd go
through some stuff on say the moon not
all the sudden you'd have a strike
available on the moon and that would be
might be the thing that if you finish
that you had enough level to go on to
the next planet or something like that
same thing like have the connection of
like some story missions maybe a strike
maybe a few
more story missions then introduce the
other strike have it be one can cut like
one consecutive thing that builds into
hey the rate is coming and this will be
and that's just part of your cutscenes
and just have it one big thing so mind
like you is that connection with the
story as one big thread just one big
thread all the way through that's to see
that's kind of a hard one for me I think
for me that gameplay mode is probably
going to be it don't know what it is but
for me I want something and I think we
talked about it before whatever it's
called in halo like warzone or something
I want a PDE slash PvP or I want I want
something bigger it's not just patrols
ok strikes or crucible I need a force
even just if it's something I can jump
into and like even casually do with like
other people in matchmaking or whatever
this mode is I don't know but I need I
want something one other piece in there
because it's like peanut he's cool um
strikes they're kind of their thing but
like story missions there's no point to
go back to and patrols it's everything
is patrols mmm everything is patrols in
public events and we've like you know
beaten those to death so I think for me
it's gonna be I want that game mode for
me is gonna be hopefully the the other X
Factor yeah those are probably my three
i'm hype i'm hype i mean like i said we
know we don't get to crazy but we do
know that everyone i went to the destiny
summit that they're under under NDA
currently right now all the big
youtubers you know everyone said that
they are so excited from a lot of
different aspects from you know that new
gameplay mode to mechanic changes
weapons lot you know a lot of the stuff
that the major destiny community has
been complaining the d one guys have
been complaining and they're saying that
all those things they're very positively
impressed by after seeing this september
I mean the September DLC so
yeah I mean we can see what's gonna go
this year - man I'm high yeah it's and
that's kind of one of those that's like
only thing I do want to say is we still
have to temper our expectations I want
it to be amazing
but but but again this is like everybody
has this is like the straw that breaks
the camel's back like make-or-break
moment of destiny - and it's just like I
can understand why because people have
waited a long enough time to be like is
this actually going to get fixed right
or not and I mean you've had a full year
you're doing a reveal like they're
they've had their time so now I've got
to see if they could use the thingy they
had it has to be amazing because I'm not
they're in trouble that's why I was like
and I mean there's still people around
playing this and they've done steps in
the right direction but for a big fill
back into that player base to pull
people away from stuff they're hooked on
like just even to pull somebody off a
twitch from watching ninja seriously
there's a million people watching the
guy you got to pull them away with a
reason to play and that's that's I think
the thing all of us want is a reason to
play be it for you the grind be it the
story connection for the arc the story
connection for the raid stuff that makes
sense in that category a story that
actually matters random gear girls all
those things we all want a reason and if
you do you're right now if you finish up
your powerful Ingram's a lot of us don't
have that reason so yep oh that we will
know more Tuesday but look for look for
us on Tuesday afternoon so it's gonna be
I mean I don't know when you're gonna
wake up I get off work at like 1:30 2
o'clock Central Texas soon as start time
for that the stream happens am i so
here's that here's my only question ok
if we can actually go check an archive
for this thing
would you prefer to watch it live so
literally like we could watch it live a
little okay pause it
hold on okay we get to talk like and we
may be pausing and talking for a while
but it's actually go through this thing
just watch you don't live like the
people are gonna want to be watching it
live in conjunction that's the only
thing so like as much as I want to stop
it
you know say like I could tell I don't
know you guys we what do you guys think
in chat like let us know do you want us
to watch it like fresh live with our
real reactions as we go through or do
you want us to like pre watch it and
pick out the pieces and then talk to you
guys about them let us know check
because we definitely definitely um want
to get your feedback for how you guys
want us to do it as far as like yeah
watching live stop and going or just
wink everything's completed and then
give our reactions post stream so we put
it on you guys which which guys want so
we'll see we'll figure that one out for
Tuesday but one way or another that day
that afternoon at least when I get home
we're gonna be talking about all of
what's to come them cell mm-hmm alright
so which coach says you watch it with us
but does it beating so doe but the
question is do you want us to do it just
like so yeah it was like so if this is
right here if you guys can see it on
screen if this is a video and we're like
okay I pull up the twitch archive and
I've got it on screen and we're like
going through all of a sudden I hit play
and we're looking old crap pause okay
you guys want to sing it
he prefers a live initial reaction so
you can see kognito cry lose it laughs
all right that's two you might have to
put a pull out there check them out a
bit absolutely yeah so I was like that's
just good that's gonna be hard I mean
you if you will just go to sleep and not
wake up that'll let me come home but and
I just have to like blow up your phone
until you get your butt out of it I'm
getting up sleep-deprived and all gonna
be noon your time you're gonna be middle
like middle of the day so if you wait a
couple hours get a few more hours of
sleep you won't be dead for your next
day so ol same ol same figure but yeah
we will do that one way or another we
will talk about it all so Tuesday we
shall be back yes okay so yeah I mean
year two is coming I don't have a clue
what the reef is gonna hold what Fallin
we're gonna fight what it changes are
gonna happen but I can't wait and it's
so close it's like a shock yeah again
that's what I was saying like some of
these times I wonder
what are we gonna talk about this
weekend flashpoint in that Bowl gonna be
cool I do like the fact that I'm Scott
Taylor and I don't know Steve cotton but
I know Scott Taylor I recognize the name
so I don't see Luke Smith I don't see
Mark Noseworthy in here this was kind of
a one question I had on three yeah the
trifecta the hat trick whoa
sitting out there so yes no yeah I was
like they're really quiet most of the
time so we'll see because they still
seem to work there so yeah we got this
to be big enough to justify and then
we'll see how it goes all right um so
Vicarious Visions they had their little
bungee versus stream and I say one by
what I'm catching in Twitter didn't
actually get to see it so that was cool
um you know Vicarious Visions they're
definitely getting in there so I like to
see that they've got a studio really
involved in helping them like helping
them but almost kind of like I don't
know if co-developing because I know
Bungie is definitely gonna be bigger
than bigger than vicarious nice steel I
just like the fact that they're they're
kind of they got part of their family
now they're building up their brand to
have more people involved and the more
people to help make this game is better
because they need more people it seems
like so more the merrier faction rallies
yes sir let's go
I love Allan Tuesday patch notes you'll
get more information about faction
rallies later I'm like really so first
off you guys can see the banners up top
yes this is what I'm talking about so
you got this little light ship wake of
dead orbit but you've also got this
little dragon wrapped around a little
logo mean angle that's pretty cool
war cult apparently was like okay we've
been to the Leviathan we're gonna take
their blue and put their purple and gold
you're gonna wrap it around art logo and
then new monarchy went straight-up
ornamental like Victorian a very Torian
yeah so
I mean hey ornate details on something
like this oh it's cool so always cool
those are a good start so two things
they wanted with affection or a lease
they wanted pledging to affection and be
a more meaningful choice and straight-up
first dot pledging to one faction per
count and their age straight up in chat
Blizzard beats dead orbit let's go orbit
or dead have a conversation with Jo I'll
be like hey I love this I continue then
we go talk about this I'm on reputation
progress is retained through multiple
events so as you can probably guess the
way we see an iron banner and now
Vanguard up to level 50 this is probably
going to be something similar each
faction offers unique rewards such as
exotic armor ornaments and mat or best
work catalysts for exotic weapons now
this is an interesting one
whoa you take a catalyst of which
everybody's a chance to get the gun but
you don't have a chance to get every
catalyst that's that's kinda one of them
all but I got to decide choices have to
be made there's gonna be some real ones
I got I already I feel like I know who's
gonna win though because I know the
popularity of it sandbox right now so
there's gonna be three faction rallies
over the course of season three and
there's a couple other pieces that will
get there in a sec but dead orbit will
offer the eye of another world ornament
anatot Lance catalyst looks the picture
and then we've got new monarchy will
offer the crest of alpha loop i ornament
which i like to actually use that thing
a lot for solo so i'll become curious
but I probably won't steer me for an
ornament
sweet business catalyst which forget
what that one does I don't even know
stability oh yes business is uh is uh
it's wack it's like um Medusa's flinch
damage when it's in the spin up I'm like
really I mean I guess if you got to hold
it on target look let's just keep it
real
my new monarch you've been winning too
much they had to give them something not
as appealing we all know everybody wants
that graphics the matter that's the
matter in it since the buff is that
vigilance wing and maybe third place
will be crimson but it really I mean
crimp which call it uh grab someone is
believe especially it grabs on has a
wave right now so yeah and no disrespect
the SunShot but um yeah I mean I know
everyone we doing yeah I was like and
it's like I have another world it's a
fairly generic use warlock I've the
knucklehead radar I mean just like you
do competitive not there crest about
blue a fee I don't mind but those are
ornaments cosmetics won't be a gameplay
changing thing for me so I don't Lance
just a must so dead orbit we're just
gonna see that as the winner next on two
weeks so Geo ahead and jump on the train
this is Jim Lewis right now so but we've
got a picture of each one so each
faction now features ranks which players
can reach by earning faction tokens
faction rank up rewards will continue to
grant legendary armor and weapons past
rank thirty so for example this is dead
orbit so I think this is your eye of
another worlds ornament right here looks
pretty cool this is the little like bird
ship thing that's in the emblem
here's your armor so I really really
like this logo on the right hand side
absolutely sick it's like the sword
threads through straight through the
dragon and this like bird ship thing
playing away I'm not sure that but
colors are very unique dunno Lincoln I
was like it's got like the stripes
through it and stuff like that but it
doesn't like pop and this is again where
if it's pretty I know where people are
gonna go but still you've got a chance
what looks like a sniper rifle you got a
ship I'm gonna guess that's like a hand
cannon and it looks to be copying the
model of something like dire promise the
revolver type and then your catalyst so
that's that orbit mmm-hmm most people
are probably gonna be there for just the
catalyst alone yeah which is cool only
my only be four dead or but he's like
I'm like why are they going away from
not giving them just plain old dark
black shaders it's like they don't want
to do it
now they won't like black white and
green oh yeah I don't know like the
green is your rap throughout wherever
it's that I guess we'll see but I mean
Laura's gonna probably be a lot of dead
orbit running rounds we'll see how it
looks can't tell why next we have this
is the ornate fancy new monarchy
executor Hideo yeah ma means we now this
is Lake this is the level of detail like
art team seriously over there guys
they're just crushing it absolutely like
this looks amazing
so the shoulder piece now unfortunately
you can see now they got the art team to
get like a new a wrap on there they got
a new skin but this is the exact same
model that's in there right now so the
models are not gonna change it is gonna
be like what it looks like so those are
gonna be there for your ornaments we've
got what is he holding that one guys I'm
for a scout yeah that looks like a
little SMG and I guess this will be a
pulsar Scout get your ship
I like the ornament looks pretty cool
and then your sweet business again these
things right here this little icon just
like I love the design of this it's so
cool and then finally we've got future
war cult so this is gonna be your black
with like gold and blue I guess that
seems to be your trend so this one we've
got a sparrow not a ship I guess that's
up to you
rocket launcher big massive thing we got
here knucklehead radar Truman literally
doesn't look any different
what's the difference yeah there's not
much it's a different color scheme but
I'm like if it's knucklehead like make
it give me a Cyclops like go just go
bananas for it with something a little
different and then I don't know if this
is a scout who knows what but I don't
think future or cults gonna be getting a
lot of love I could see new monarchy
going for like looking pretty if people
get what they want from dead orbit I
could see pneumonic you probably going
next unless future war cult just has
like amazing perks or something who
knows but we've got more to it as well
so they want faction rallies to provide
a unique gameplay experience you want to
jump into this little mulch
here little discussion pull it up so we
are at uh where Anna you want to talk
about the post factional rally stuff
yeah images yeah so pretty much they're
gonna provide a unique experience and
then they talked about this renowned
system and um this is actually pretty
cool yeah and actually what I'm liking
is that it says after pledging to a
faction players may earn renown by
completing public event Patrol defeating
a high-value target
yada-yada players who loot a loss sector
with renowned active we will see
significantly more faction tokens than
usual more stacks we now they have the
more faction tax tokens they earn renown
is lost when players are defeated by
enemies so be careful when you're
attempting to loot a sector with the
high renown now here's the thing about
renown which I thought I didn't realize
I was like wow this is cool now renowned
the more renowned you get it increases
the level of challenge in gameplay
health generational regeneration is
vastly reduced then it's all stacked
levels enemy kills have a chance to drop
health or ball stack levels player
damage decreased skills back skills
would stack up to five and incoming
damage increase skills will stack up to
five so the more renowned you get the
harder it is to retain that renowned
because the game is kind of ramping up
in difficulty and that's a cool mechanic
I think yeah I was like that's at least
a step in the right direction of taking
of a gameplay that's normally just
rolling around in patrols and giving it
some difficulty so I do like this this
is a cool step first thing right now and
like you like ya are gonna be doing your
public events patrols doing your basic
stuff what stuff start gonna start
getting harder like I actually like that
that's kind of cool
I mean if you're doing the I think
people are gonna be skipping the
injection a written public event a lot
yeah because that thing will kill you
yeah so yeah it's gonna make you think
though I mean if you're going for that
big stack and you're going for a long
grind you're like hey we're gonna do
this I mean I don't now here's the other
pieces though we have all these
different rewards like these all look
like things like these are the armor
sets these the weapons that are
now there are specific ones you can get
photos like there's already so much to
go after it's like I kind of wonder what
is like if you win the week is it really
going to matter or is people just gonna
be grinding for whatever they choose mmm
no I mean as far as like the winning
weapon kind of dude like what would you
think when we yeah I mean so we have the
winning weapons they're right down here
got a rocket launcher for a new Marquis
shotgun for dead orbit and well-baby
sidearm down here but it's just like
okay so this is just another one we know
they aren't changing that much right now
we're not gonna have anything out there
too far so is this going to be your
driving factor of whatever wins now or
is it just go loot loss sectors and yeah
my motivation is what is it ranked 50 or
whatever that rank is to get the damn
catalyst or the get the damn one okay I
guess I'm not thinking about this right
I guess the more renowned you have the
more tokens you have the faster you'll
get your level that's gonna give you a
benefit I guess my motivation I'm only
dead orbit it's it's nothing new Marquis
nothing personal I'm here with that
orbit for my clip for my catalyst its
back and do it I got a do you know make
my pledge and then next week you know
maybe future Walker have something a
little better cuz I just know I mean
enough you walk on Newmark you have some
a little better because I'm just not
feeling this election this week but I
like the fact that it's forcing a choice
you know I mean and whatever has
whatever you want you go for it then
yeah I was like this when you're in
third-person view or people are looking
at you you got your vaction stuck on
your back like a like a sign this is
kind of amazing
that's pretty cool and they say
something about you can see that with
third-person view or something like that
yeah it says renown displays which
faction Guardian has pledged to but only
from third-person this function applies
to all players that's pretty cool I like
that Wow well renowned is active on a
player others around them can see I
wonder if this is actually gonna have
like stages of like if this is like
stage 5 oh and then you like if you get
because they say stacks like up to 5 so
like stack one is a little smaller - it
grows more and more and then if you get
5
this is like going to keep this guy
alive he's on a good run help him out
come on like I wonder who actually could
escalate in the animation it's actually
show how many stacks you have going on
so right but these already blow away
every aura I've seen in the game oh yeah
so raid the hardest guy seemed like none
of that stuff is even close this just
blows it away this is a step in the
right direction and again animation art
team sweet but this right here you slap
this on my back when I'm running around
the tower and it's like prestige raid is
like you know this giant gold crown or
something hovering over my head that's
the type of stuff oh when I seize it
take this and make it bigger for the
nightfall like yes you got to go big in
this gonna go big yeah gotta go crazy
with it that's what we've always talked
about past flash points mmm
yeah seriously it's like a 1 I think and
this is what I was talking to you about
and this is one we'll get to crucible
abs discussion here in a minute yeah I
want them to step out of the comfort
zone box of what you know they think
either fits in the lore or just the
sci-fi game and be be okay breaking some
of that immersion occasionally just to
be like to reward your players they know
they're still playing the game yeah it's
cool to have the story the immersion the
characters all that stuff but like go
out of the way show some crazy stuff
sometimes and I really really like this
I want more more the step stuff if you
do this on a set of armor from the raid
yeah then I'm gonna grind the living
crap out of it cuz it looks amazing if
you give me ornaments that look like
they're from d1 age of triumph yes
you'll find me in cooler stuff yes they
want it to be cosmetic you can do it
let's keep it up so I don't know who's
gonna win actually I do
I hope everybody enjoys their shotgun
because that's what's gonna be the one
yes with it so action rallies be coming
and it's Tuesday so Tuesday reveal I'm
gonna work come home and crank it up
login then when you wake up turn it off
you know it it's like yeah you too
definitely kicks the crap out of faction
rallies but I look this is this is
at least enough of like a take away and
come back that I'm okay with it
this was no what do you think what are
you gonna grade this is like you know
give it a letter grade ABC as far as in
place what I feel overall yep be honest
it be plush up it'll be a more solid be
stepping in my direction yeah I like it
I mean it's not perfect um a couple
things I want improved but I think a lot
of it just comes down to the weapon
portion is always gonna be trash and two
random rules are implemented in the game
so yeah that that's that's when I think
you're gonna see faction rally actually
have more meaning and grinding for
weapons but for right now it's really
just the armor sets you know the
ornaments and the catalyst you know that
kind of stuff so yeah I'm with you there
because in all honesty that's about
right that's probably what I would say
as well because the other systems in the
game need to be fixed to allow this to
get better and until it does
as you said grinding for the factions
getting your armor it's like okay yeah
it's another paint job and if I really
want to look different like I did for
new monarchy I might grind it for a bit
but once I've got it then I really will
be done like so there's no point to keep
pressing through and so that stuff
crossed my fingers so yeah we up faction
Ally's be got yourself an eighty
eighty-five somewhere I mean for what
that what they're able to change in
which this is gonna be a big discussion
next for what faction rallies is able to
change I think they did what they could
like we have citizens they have to work
with now that being said I'm gonna jump
to a different tab here let's go
hold on oh one thing about this is Josh
hammers Twitter now if you don't follow
him do because he's definitely involved
in the sandbox and a lot of things he
had a pretty funny gift right here but
this tweet actually had me concerned
I had nothing in bold in big letters to
do with or even knew much about the
faction around the changes after reading
the tuam he was stoked about the details
this is your sandbox guy hahaha
not knowing not knowing what is gonna
change this faction rallies
see that is what worries me about the
communication within the studio and that
is why sometimes we wonder how do
certain things happen how does an iron
banner ornament come out in ever verse
when you have an ornament that comes out
on the raid that you can randomly get on
a drop that's really cool how do those
happen at the same time this seems to be
a prime example you know that I mean I
don't know that happens it just shows
the lack of basically what it's showing
me they're just showing me that each
team is in its own individual bubble
there's no continuity and the groups are
not communicating so you know they may
have whoever's the lead over all these
groups it's inexcusable that look I
understand you got your nose to the
grindstone and you're trying to make
things happen and everything is crunch
moment I get that but all I'm saying is
like you said with something like the
emote where the raid guys made it a
reward for an activity but then somehow
when the iron banner comes around an
ever verse emote is in there that you
could only get from that verse and
spending half the money of the dlc so
the messages get lost and and that's
still a problem as a studio they've got
to figure that out that like you've got
to be you know I don't care if you get
one member of each team and you have a
weekly update hey this is what we're
doing this is weird
oh wait a minute we did that last week
oh we can't do that with you more that's
the problem you know I'm saying like it
I don't know as a studio how you can
operate like that man like that's just
me you know saying like I get it they're
trying to fix the game was a lot of
teams going on the fan base is you know
very demanding I get that but
communication within your own studio
needs to happen I mean I thought yeah
that's a must and this is while it's
like hey he's stoked about it man
graphic it's just kind of funny around
here girls and I'm like an idiot
that being said is like even you're not
talking to those people and you don't
know that's a problem you're in the
studio you're like the you're the
sandbox like lead basically is what I'm
gathering from all the teams like if
you're involved in all the
implementations like hey if if I bump up
buff up this little like shotgun a
little bit okay
or butts gonna have a beast gun over
there or if a rocket launcher perk a
little bit like those are gonna your
systems talk to each other I don't want
to make it seem like me disrespecting
just like a great guy and I'm not I just
shows the culture of the studio that you
know a member of a certain team doesn't
know what another team is doing like
that's a problem that's a bigger
cultural problem that they still have to
fix so there's one of the point so
that's a good good catchy next let me
talk about lab work so crucible labs
have you had a chance to jump into that
yet I have not and the reason why is
your meaning you were texting now and
you're discussed said I'm not even
touched and then I watched someone is
video I think was character shy of the
cactus really I get him on the show um
like and I was just like that's all it
is it did once it didn't what you
describe the mode and I'm like oh but
I'll let you take this section this is
this is oh yeah just on me thanks I'm
gonna need so I'm gonna need this is a
two-person podcast here man come on oh
so crucible Labs part of it again is
their delivery and this is where it's
the it's the way they do messaging they
want to keep things a secret and they
like they're really great at hype but
you got a Wado
got la sorry talking sorry they have to
watch their expectations with their hype
yes with what the audience wants mm-hmm
so that is step one to this so what is
crucible abs what did people think
before it came out you're thinking
public test realm you're thinking a way
to test time to kill in air accuracy
different weapons all that type of stuff
people are get hyped they're talking
about this all that stuff like the day
before it drops and this is when I
texted you and you're seriously going
okay what do they do all they can do
this is literally a crucible testing
grounds but all they can test is game
modes curse herbal settings so literally
you limit yourself to literally mode
types which this was a new one we'll get
to in a second maybe you do hey we're
heavy ammo spawns or heavy ammo timing
or spawn timings I mean you are limited
to things truly just like your playlist
settings and ammo spawns and spawn
points and stuff like that and that
seems to be all I can think of right and
what people wanted was a public test
from hey it can time to kill get any
quicker can we make let me know as
literally to listen to DCP just for a
second it was like they're talking about
oh this will be cool it'll be a chance
for B you know see can we do three shot
hand cannons can you try that stuff out
none of that stuff is in there they said
it is no sandbox changes mm-hmm
disappointed so that's like a huge
letdown for I think oh what a lot of
people hoped this was right now they did
try to get in front of it right and try
to say why are we gonna get into you
know they they can't they couldn't do
what they actually didn't explain here
but they um it was on Twitter and they
kind of basically said I guess someone
asked like hey like the same thing like
this pointing you know why can't we have
that and apparently the answer was
because the way the engine is set up if
they make any changes sandbox wise there
it affects the entire game so I kind of
get that but at the same time it's just
like okay so then what really is the
purpose of this mode you know are we
just going to debut different game types
here and that's it you know I know it's
a little sad that you know we're not
gonna get any type of sandbox change
testing in here in a full-fledged kind
of way but you know I'm gonna hope that
they get involved it evolves into
something else but I do I I'm with you
II like when we got the announcement I
had very high expectations you know I'm
very hopeful and then when we actually
got it and based on what you've guys
told me you know it's just like you know
this is double-doubles
but it so the game mode they got
announced was called showdown and
basically what it was is 4v4 so not even
changing the number of players involved
4v4 clash but just in time drowns that's
it it was best out of five how many
kills you get your super energy carries
over heavy doesn't so it does help reset
heavy which I'm okay with the rounds are
two and a half minutes long my opinion
on that too long mm-hmm I would rather
have a best-of-seven of like a minute
round maybe have a chance to pick up one
you might get your super in like you
know the third or fourth or maybe the
last one if you go for long or you save
it for later round and you have a little
more tactics to it but two and a half
minutes we were getting quite a few
kills each round it was a lot so I mean
between my it was probably 20 or 30 I
mean yeah and that's a long time when
you have to potentially do that five
times they could be a really long match
I did I went three and oh I got lucky
like June so but my marathon that was
like my three you know is still with the
time in between matches the little bit
of downtime probably was like a ten
minute match it could have been fifteen
if the other two were in there so yeah I
think the time on this one was a little
long I see what they were doing like you
won't have people runner if people get
hold of the heavy and really start
running it you can kind of take over a
match same thing that you do is level so
if you re wipe the slate on heavy every
round super energy stays and that builds
which I'm kind of okay with but if heavy
gets wiped every round and it was coming
up every thirty seconds that still
seemed pretty rampant right but you
won't have a team just own it the whole
time so or if you just absolutely botch
round one and you're like okay half my
team fell asleep and then they woke up
in the end and now we're gonna play the
other three you could have a chance at
some comeback so like in theory the
rounds aren't terrible my thing with you
was like even if you're only gonna
change settings which I am as I was
saying with you it's like okay we're
just only doing crucible we can't touch
sandbox cool I I mean I understand
they're stuck it's like it is a game
where if you touch a weapon it affects
it everywhere in the game you can't bill
make hand cannons crazy or you're gonna
go break the raid or strikes or whatever
and it kind of sucks but I get the
technical limitations I understand it at
least yeah what I want them to do with
this is get a little crazy with things
at least in modes get a little step
outside of your comfort bubble don't
have your toes still in them in the pool
like step out and run the other
direction see what happens mm-hmm do
like 6v6
and you know 66 supremacy go threes I
want to see like 3 V 3 V 3 I would like
if they can do it come on put people on
different teams go run around make it
kind of insane like at least mess around
as far as you can within your crucible
box if you're stuck in the box
mm-hmm as much as you can this seems
like we're like I'm in my little bubble
I'm gonna like I'm gonna peek outside up
nope nevermind I'll be right here like
so I mean their questions are what I
think about the mode okay
still very tame I don't I guess but the
other pieces that a lot of people are
asking for that I saw the most of they
want objective modes they're dying for
them yeah
oddball what are you sure the flag they
want an objective mode because it's like
I don't need another just shoot people
in the face playlist I need a reason to
move to a certain place any reason to
defend or protect or work as a team or
flank or I need a reason
I've got enough playlist to shoot people
and I think that's we've got clash we've
got supremacy which is shoot people and
then be by their body we have control
which is the only objective thing we've
got so that countdown but I think we
have enough shooting in the face
give me a reason to go do that oh yes
absolutely and I'm hoping my hope is
that it will evolve into that and we'll
see things like rift will see other
modes and maybe they want to try to
implement in there you know kind of
thing and um you know I mean I'm hoping
listen my whole thing is I can't stand
trials online I would love 3 man
elimination again the old-school way you
know I mean what if they did a rumble
king of a hill
it would also be kind of crazy which
would be fun the point moves every
minute or so so you're not just the
longest you stay in there but that's the
type of stuff like Rumble king of the
hill as you said 3v3 eliminations like
make it some real game mode changes not
just clash for time and rounds like that
was when you say you want to test
something I want you to test something
that you probably can't be like yeah
you'd probably do this in-house well
this is what I want you to see if the if
the world likes it or not by getting
outside of your comfortable game mode so
they're asking was anything confusing my
big foot if it was I'm sorry for the
player who's confused because it was
very very simple we've done it before
did you did anything seem missing I'm
gonna save my thoughts there but but I
would just use one word creativity yes
was there a map to play it on better or
worse it's clash so if it works on clash
it's still there where they're spawning
issues and these are all questions if it
was a real mode yeah I'd be happy to
answer em but right now it's just clash
for time I can only have a few questions
about how the rounds work so we'll see
where the rounds too long too short yeah
too long that would be my one spawning
issues I didn't really seem to notice
them too bad up in her saying boss
combination that affected gameplay not
really so what's up Chronos in chat how
you guys doing
shout out to chat on both sides of this
equation by the way mmm
so I mean crucible labs and I know this
is like a baby step they may have just
wanted to see if it was gonna work
before they don't break something and
they do want you to know if stuff does
break in there remember it's a test but
I do want them to try and break it as
well mm-hmm that's part of the fun of a
test so you got to see what happens when
you go too far otherwise you're never
gonna know so oh escalation protocol do
we change it again so not quite what I
was hoping for yeah I talked my butt off
about the last one I'm going to pass the
mic back escalation protocol as they say
it's been a hot topic so they got the
design lead was named Benton and uh
men won't act and make some changes to
the experience so both of them have said
that the update will go live this woman
this weekly update goes live power
levels from escalation more protocol
enemies will be lowered in way four
through seven ways one two three are
unchanged and will remain at 370 power
so still watch out for that level - was
itwas hahaha players who still plays who
have stayed on Mars since before this
update we need to turn over a net on
Mars again so the old values waves one
two three with 370 waves four and five
385 and wave six and seven or 400 now
with the new values the first three
waves will remain the same at 370 waves
four and five go down from 25 to 380 and
when six and seven go down significantly
from 400 to 385 and then they continue
to go on
you know on why how they're making the
change and they talk about the you know
server flags and I can switch between
power levels and didn't quite download
and the reasons for the change and this
is these are the key points they say
they've been looking at the internal
data and they listening to all the
feedback about escalation protocol since
the launch warmind and now okay what
they're saying is what if they did this
is a funny but not as many players are
attempting escalation protocol with a
fireteam of three as our designs
intended mostly because of how difficult
wave six and seven are tweaking the
difficulty in wave six and seven very
quickly to power levels changes is
something we can do right away because
the server Flags mentioned above rather
than waiting a number of weeks to
deliver a patch by reducing the power
levels of the later waves we were
intending to make escalation protocol
more approachable for players who want
to try the activity at 385 as a fireteam
of 3 haha
with the tentative help from others in
the world getting nine players into the
same space will still be possible but
for those at or close to max level it
shouldn't feel as necessary as before if
anyone is worried that we're nerfing
this activity into the ground rest
assured that it will still be highly
difficult in highly difficult endgame
experience or the mechanics timers at
enemy behaviors will remain in change so
you still should plan to bring your best
team gear and strategies to succeed
so I have a lot to say about this but
I'm gonna let no no no you got a lot to
say you just got like I don't know if
you breathed in there that was
impressive but go for it first I got my
thoughts I I vented last week you
weren't even here here's the thing um I
completely the this this escalation
protocol thing I'm calling the fiasco
I've been completely disagreement with
them I don't like the thought process I
don't like a lot of it here's my thing
okay first of all it's supposed to be um
high in activity right I get that aspect
but the issue really to me is it waves
four and five like you know I'm saying
like I don't think that's the issue you
know say my thing is you've got to get
the entry level in because what's gonna
happen is yes we want this content to be
hard right but if you're getting pumped
stomped in brown one right new casual
they're not even has anybody who wants
to keep trying the activity is gonna get
discouraged and then you're just
worrying about getting your light level
up so my thing is why not have the
opposite effect when you make waves one
and two a little bit ease of entry and
then it's this gradual skill progression
right so then it's like okay now okay
pull me down to two
I gotta get better now I gotta go level
up I gotta go get crying to get my light
up you know this way it's like if you're
370 with the new values 370 then you get
the 380 they're making it a gradual
climb from the middle and I mean I don't
think necessarily this is the best way
to handle it and then ultimately my main
beef which is the elephant in the room
is we know damn well this is not a 3-man
activity like they keep pissing me off
like all we're supposed to do this for 3
min this is not a 3-man activity this is
people are in there doing Nintendo
switch friend calls just to get other
people in nah man I'm not doing like
that that is so antiquated and it's
embarrassing because d-1 had that you
would think that like they would put a
flag in the middle of the you know
whatever the protocol touch the flag
everybody kind of check in who's jumping
in and
get 69 why is that so hard to do like
what look I'm not a dev I'm not gonna
try to disrespect anybody but don't
insult my intelligence by saying that
this activity is three men there's no
way there's no you've got to be the most
coordinated you know and you guys are
all got to be 385 you know I mean mm-hmm
at minimum five to six plus so it's just
like I don't like their answer to me the
screams we don't have the dev time to
put in a proper matchmaking mode for
this yeah and I understand
did they drawn the line in the sand as
far as not changing entry level that's
what it seems to be like they like no
keep it hard we're gonna keep okay fine
but do realize you know that at the end
of the day like you know a lot of people
are gonna get discouraged you're gonna
do round one you do round till you get
stomped and you know again I'm not
trying to catalyze it that I'm not going
there I'm just saying just a slight bump
to the initial levels to get more people
to get encouraged and then it's like
okay now in levels three and four you
know that's it everything else ain't
undisputed but I have rambled floor is
[Laughter]
great so this literally brings up a
couple things that I was reading from
Paul Tassie's article last week do you
see it
yeah so and this is kind of a thing too
you've got your levels of challenge you
want it to be in-game and honestly think
they did in the wrong direction
same thing you're saying give the new
people a chance to step into it but make
the final challenge in the game level so
you want to know so they're not they
already have two things Paul testing so
that we're really really good one roared
every level yeah yeah no reason to do
that crap even if it's just tokens as
all you're gonna throw up me right now
oh now we double chatting
so how do you get more people to do it
how do you have an event last longer how
do you have your server get involved
have three like a couple people that are
walking around who just in a public
event one of them starts it up
hey this first wave is 3:40 not 370 mm
okay you got it going you're working Oh
somebody loads into the zone hey we got
one going on this is level one sweet I
can jump in even if I'm low okay two
goes and you can just show the light
level up there'd be like all right level
two parentheses 350 okay going against
this wizard who keeps pissing me off
sweet okay we're working through alright
sweet we got that up 360 okay now I'm
starting to die a lot more okay I'm
about 360 but you give feeling of some
accomplishment right they want it too
casual eyes this game so much they took
it too far
mm-hmm then you take something like this
and you take it out of reach for all
your casual arty completely completely
just put it way up on the pedestal at
the top of the mountain people are like
I can't I can't you know I'm at the
first base camp of Everest and you guys
set it on the peak like yeah we got it
we got a build up to get there and you
gotta give your face a chance to build
through it like if you want people to
get used to these things get used to
working together the one where it's the
the reverse curl tonight yeah where you
have to use the sword to sew the shield
job to show ya and every giant enemy
every single giant enemy and destiny and
I wish they all didn't do this stomps
the ground kills you mm-hmm oh yes this
ain't mechanic yeah yeah I was like come
on get creative every but like you have
to have a Titan with a bubble there yeah
then you have to be doing the swords
popping and now trying to slam that
thing in there and there's like six
people doing this well some are staying
on the back as soon as it's going to
start shooting them to do that with
three people on the level seven boss of
a hundred is just absolutely insane
mm-hmm so but I like in turn if you had
built up the other thing Paul test he
said do it like a public event and put a
damn timer on it how do you get people
in the same spot give them a time for
him when it starts do a rally to the
flag have a timer that starts it
they already have it for public events
don't do it rent don't have and that's
the thing he said it perfectly he didn't
his article shoutout I'd love to have
him on here yeah TAS sees him how he
he's the elusive man cocky try
I was like he's at Forbes he's probably
got so many like India's and stuff I'm
sure he can't be touched but he's gonna
predict his job he got a good one
that being said like the way he phrased
it like put a timer out there do it ten
minutes between each side ten minutes to
get it started I don't even know how
long it takes but if you do a 15 min
timer and you know it's coming no way
okay fine I'll go run around I'll do a
patrol or shoot a few things I might go
grab a bowl of cereal who knows whatever
it is I know that team that see the
people on that server or if you get all
nine people who see that and they load
in you're gonna get people to do groups
at a time and even at a point when it's
not as popular later on you'll still
have people who can at least rally
together mm-hmm so the timer's was good
it's a mechanic you already have four
public events and the other problem is
like you'd have L we did a public event
cool let me go start this real quick cuz
everybody's here then they finish their
public event milestone they left and
then you have like one person with you
and you just get destroyed
yeah so you need a better way to start
it one that's a little more yeah Phil's
your super all that stuff so I mean look
how give yourself a progression I'm with
you I still don't think they're doing
all right
I want a progression to get into it I
don't care if they leave the top at 400
if you go 340 350 360 370 380 390 400
that's a progression to fight through
and you got to be that elite you got to
be that group and you got to get a
coordinated like effort going there to
make it happen and it's probably not
gonna happen every time but that's how
you make it an in-game thing where it's
a challenge so no I had my rain last
week I'll try and cut it here but I mean
I did I literally went through all those
left when I'm with you bro like I'm with
you the mentality behind this escalation
protocol the way they can and I want is
I want to make a point though cuz I know
you know some people like hey you guys
are hypocrites because when you when
this game was dead and you guys are
complaining about casualisation I can
hear little voices in the background
right I know you know and I get that
always saying is this is bad level
design it has nothing to do with not
making the activity challenging we want
the activity to be challenging that's
fine but the entry level like the cost
of entry like it's just like the
equivalent of starting the raid
in the first in you encounter is Calais
like there has to be a build-up right
until you get to Calais right you had
the dish you had to sleeping you know
you're the dogs or whatever there were
certain activities like you had the the
courtyard where you have to you know do
the symbols and carry the crest and all
that other stuff there's a [ __ ] that's
what we said you can't start an activity
and just be completely crushed
demoralize based in your life and then
you're like okay we're gonna fix it when
you get to the fourth level level of the
valorization
we're gonna bring it down and I'm like
hold on everybody's dying on the wizard
you even referenced the damn wizard
exactly I don't know what health that
thing has I've dumped a lot of Darcy
into that thing and I feel like I'm
throwing pennies at the guy like I'm not
doing anything and last but not least
stop disrespecting us with this three
main activity gah like when we see all
YouTube stream is getting nine people
together just to do and we know the sad
thing is it's from from what people at
socks I've never done it yet the most I
probably seen is like six I haven't even
got close to that you're like I've seen
oh yeah as a PC anything like that but
it's like the most I've seen is sixth
and us doing it and from what I hear and
what I see it is sounds like the most
fun thing in destiny people are telling
me like you're when you get when you do
the friend code and you got nine it is
amazing now you have your community
loving something
can we not implement something to
accommodate that you know but anyway so
yeah I mean and that's the same thing
I've heard too it's like people love
this game-mode like people work to get
nine people together I know some people
want to grind up is to get the highest
stuff and trying to get the fastest you
know way to get something mm-hmm
but if the mode sucked people would not
put the effort in in like ours so try
and be like alright we got another guy
here let's invite him in get somebody
and kick him out thank you for your
service
passive on like all they're not going to
go through all that effort
to do some activity that just sucks hmm
good night
so I mean it seems like a really cool
activity the Horde wave the escalation
and that's the thing it was like I don't
care if wave seven stays at 400 exactly
like now my only issue with that is what
we get to when we talk about what they
did in crota you were max of 32 and you
artificially challenged with 33 for no
other reason and that's their only way
to do difficulty now games do that and
that's fine now if this was like 385 but
just you know there are more enemies
like give me more to shoot give me a
little bit overrun give me that feeling
of like frankness it's the hive that is
the theme that stuff is cool I keep the
difficulty there but as you said just
the other progression into it so yeah
you said pretty much everything I did
last week so yeah we're on the same page
but yeah it's like three man know you
want to know the people who three man
this thing it's the people who on the
raid race and that's basically the only
video I've seen it was glad and though
gay and like gigs that type of people in
the community they're known to be the
point zero one percent of the community
that's it you want a three man this
thing I mean so low a night falls I can
swing it with some time no it was like
an esoteric cos I had step above be for
sure but it was like three man this
thing man some of that stuff like if
you're Titan guys do bubble goes that
whole run is gone if you smash one tiny
thing wrong with that sword like that
one alone and then that giant ogre and
there's like fort so I mean no it's it's
meant to be I mean say you took a public
event you made it really cool well let
people play it yeah man
good old escalation close-up protocol
yep continued to be a thing we'll see
how if there's any changes I just hope
they don't keep beat there's a point of
like your community is pushing back your
communities pushing back yeah hold our
ground there's a point where when most
of your community is like hey we
introduced something hey okay we didn't
know we were gonna like this thing cool
you don't always have to go on what the
community wants because if you do you
casual eyes it you break it division did
the same thing they listen to the
community streamers they made things
they like took a little too
far but like you've you got to find a
balance absolutely what's something I
mean come on you know see anyway
another warmind coming so I was like one
too but I know these things aren't easy
to put out probably because it's like
one people an art team making a whole
thing but still I'd like to see like
three four or five I'd like to see a
little more in depth story on one of
these 84 year to give us a comic that
comes up like once a month so we
actually have a full ongoing story
mm-hmm a little more depth to it so but
I'm most curious to read it so say to
10:00 a.m. Pacific so hours to out two
hours cool yeah cool we got a whole
bunch of patch notes things like that
there I'm not gonna go through those if
you want to read those that's known
issues movies of the week all that stuff
find there's one more piece they said
another step on the road map has been
executed we have much more in store for
the coming months you're gonna make sure
you don't miss a beat subscribe via up
few subscribe for updates via bungie.net
when you invite us to keep in touch will
give us a chance to send your
communications tailored to your specific
play style you'll also earn an envelope
that will only to be displayed but for
the well informed so random little emote
which is fine you can do email
verification just get another one so
that's most of it well I got some hot
fresh off the press news oh well see
this is what happens when I've got four
screens open and I can see there's a
room attached he's got something up
right in that is a rumor sleek saying
the destiny too full of expansion is
summoning is summoning of the nine with
a new enemy race please yeah let's see
let's see go if you if you have Twitter
open he has it see if I could pull it up
for it too
look real quick well that's what happens
if you're watching live so this is
laughs yo yeah yeah keep it laughs he's
got he's got an article out there's no
rumored leak okay rumored leak so we
have to take this with a supreme grain
of salt I will say typically he's not
gonna be the one to jump on a BS type
Lee I don't see him write as many
articles that are just like hey this is
possibly out there this is mm-hmm simply
he's not I mean everybody on YouTube and
their mother's brother like they will do
leaks everywhere yes I don't think he's
as click Beatty
like so I might take at least two grains
of salt as opposed to just one here yeah
I mean you wanna see yeah okay I move it
over onto the page here real quick sorry
guys yeah we're gonna is my damn screens
here shut down if then I can pull it up
forward to and we up it's everybody can
see it cool all right so he said he's
debating on whether to discuss this leak
because few have panned out
but as e3 leaks are basically flying out
the doors right now this is a time when
things are gonna basically be having a
chance to really be this is like that
week before where things actually have a
tendency to be kind of accurate yeah
it's kind of why I think he's doing this
so because you're like hey fallout 76
and Assassin's Creed just got leaked as
well so and this is from 4chan it says
you know so will it you want to start
with the bullet before this is a so
story revolt storyline revolves around
aldrin which is the brother
resurfacing with an army of fallen
soldiers to rescue a sister from the
nine interesting nine are forced to
unleash and I'm gonna have issues saying
some of these words for advanced Nast
wrath to stop Aldrin's army brand new
enemy race of void demons seriously I
don't care if that's true that's the
level of crazy that I literally want in
this next expansion no the next one even
got me that's a warlock great um trunk
discuss here
this is what we got it is live and we
have the pause we gotta do next week's
live because I'm even have to pause
you're gonna be like play it play than
we like Oh Nasir ik which is the warlock
hell Nezzer x said the main antagonist
of the expansion besides older it
Mezrich is the former tenth member of
the nine who is banished for betraying
his brethren the expansion is called the
tomb of eternity revolves around
stopping mizerock for good the nine are
met during the expansions cap eight
campaign and help you stop nezarakku
which is like the fact that you're gonna
have a lot more NPC's mmm-hmm missions
four strikes to new destinations the
reef and the void brand new cooperative
activity called known as the court
counselor scale but it's a brand new pv
activity new to the destiny series we
know a new mode is coming now whether
something called it something and court
seems a little weird mmm because we had
court of Oryx but also you have like
nine that I could picture in like a nine
council and you're facing the court or
something they're like so a new race
that I feel it's time mm-hmm
we had a new race with taking king yes
we had a reskin a brand new race of void
demons Kanan you guys are in luck it was
crazy there's a lot of exotics that you
know kind of boost void damage in some
way now she does wrecks in it's part of
that yeah so this thing man I mean we'll
see we'll see I mean you see Tassie as
you scroll down he breaks it down a
little further as far as like legitimacy
he's like pretty much every fake destiny
to League has involved all during in
some way and um you know he's like you
know he's supposed to be a star war mine
until an embrace revealed
yadda yadda yadda and then he's like
summoning the nine does not sound like a
real expansion name I'll say that you
want to get the next bullet point as far
as what his speculation is how far you
get down here
yes isn't denying remains the most
mysterious destiny so it makes sense
after four years the game decided to
explore them a bit more
and given that one of the few complaints
about destinies that it hasn't gotten
truly new enemy race since taken see
before them frozen high all these kids
you think I mean they need my grace I
want something different and if the nine
come in if there's a story behind them I
could see it being cool now somebody
could be getting really creative here of
course it's a day but this again just
sparks more of a discussion for what we
want we want some new stuff light yeah I
mean I don't mind fighting with cabal
the high of the fallen but I have seen
them for literally four years now I've
shot the same acolytes in the face I've
seen the nights with new graphics to
them I've seen them for all like a curse
throws a cursor all they have not
changed that much their little blue
glowing head explodes I understand it
like I want something else
mm-hmm I said Nast wrath are mentioned
in a single grimoire card in teste so
it's not like it comes out of nowhere
but it really be a scarab really obscure
for a fake leaker to pull from nezarakku
you know who turned 10 into the nine it
seems that's kind of cool
tomb of eternity that sounds like as he
says it's with the void theme and tomb
of eternity for somebody banished I mean
for forever if the nine are I'm having
trouble believing Bungie will cast nine
different boys characters to play that
night they'll probably just sit there in
silence walls their talks for them
that's actually a pretty funny there's a
decent amount of story missions and
strikes first will be one will be
PlayStation exclusive I hate that but I
know I can't remember how many taken hat
taking King we had the dark blade we had
the shield brothers mm-hmm well I'm
missing one it's been a while I don't
know all that don't look real quick well
you have you go I would as soon a reef
will be another social space not that
the game will needs bear one would know
one already go into the farm the void
could be an interesting location that
isn't a specific planet like we've seen
so far nor ship like to dread that yeah
I mean it's definitely gonna sound I
mean the void what what are you gonna
wander around on the void literally like
so interesting we had shield brothers we
had the sunless sell that was the dark
blade we had the blighted chalice that
came later actually that was me all
right we had fallen Sabre that was the
nerd so there was at least three and
then echo chamber was the PlayStation
wasn't so there were four total with
PlayStation 3 for everybody else yeah so
I think we're still short there I would
like all of this I mean I still don't
see no subclass power no I know well
yeah like leaks piece at a time court
could be the totally new way to play
that was showing off when the content
creators visited this could you totally
made-up court seems like a weird word so
again take all this with a grain of salt
still room is nothing but like a new
enemy faction like something involving a
piece of story that we've been involved
with for a while that's the type of
stuff like I mean they've unfortunately
and byph is just like banging his head
against the the narrative wall over on
his side of the pond but he's literally
like you have these characters we hear
about you have Osiris this guy hey
what's up ok cool here's little blips
All Right see you later you know like I
mean we know we want the story to get
better and you have that 9 you take the
Zerg character and you screw it up
you're gonna piss off even more yeah if
something's involved and you have I mean
he's one of them he is part of the nine
right sir is or am I crazy ok so I mean
you've got him at that level people have
seen him for four years he's elusive
where does he go hmm I mean this would
be kind of a cool thing to see but I
don't know but yeah I want to do I want
a new race to fight not a reskin please
yeah I know it's gonna be interesting
with this leak you know once we do the
live thing on Tuesday you know like we
have almost like a playbook to see if it
you know what's accurate yeah this is
the bathroom yeah yeah absolutely
so Tuesday is gonna be a big one guys we
information to coordinate times like if
I make him go to sleep if we watch this
live if there's a way to check an
archive like I don't know how long the
archives take
no one way I can do it I'm gonna talk my
wife into a little bit of help
I can record the stream like source
detail yeah basically just stream that
could like the window the stream as a
video and pause and play it I know I
should may believe that okay just gotta
get my wife Courtney didn't do it it's
9:00 a.m. 11:00 a.m. trying to think of
my times for Tuesday morning I've got a
9:30 - at 10:30 I could potentially
swing home and start it myself actually
so I might do that one way or the other
we will definitely have year two to talk
about for you guys so we get a lot lot
to look forward to this is a fun time
but escalation protocol fix it but
seriously guys again you always hear the
passion from us you guys who what follow
us in chat and sit along and listen to
us ramble on for an hour and a half we
know you guys have the passion as well
so we think all you guys for your time
dealing with our ramblings are and most
of the time we feel like we don't speak
for the community but we feel like what
we've experienced suspect an idea of
what a lot of everybody's thinking I
mean I watch a lot of YouTube videos out
there to try and keep up with the other
piece of the community its we we try and
put this together and we thank you guys
and honestly a year to reveal it doesn't
get much bigger so hype train I'm on
board I always am so I can't wait
absolutely so to let the other man on
the side of this get to sleep because
we're just gonna crush his sleep
schedule next week I have to go up mind
uh find something to feed on there yeah
man yeah so I think for now follow us on
Twitter we'll keep you guys updated as
to what we're really gonna do for the
reveal but definitely look for something
on Tuesday if not look for me to upload
a video and Cognito as well to our
YouTube channels that'll be the recovery
as afterwards absolutely absolutely and
this Sunday still doing ILP
really Yop he will be popping we will
have this would be a closeout of our III
prediction series we did a Nintendo
first Sony second and this will be Xbox
and when I could suffer we've got some
pretty pretty huge that guess I guess I
can break it now on flashpoint you get
up convert yeah hopefully they follow
through but it should be um dealer
gaming ran out for and beast fired Tim
dog so we're gonna have an all-star Xbox
panel should be pretty cool and we're
gonna get into the predictions and the
State of the State of the box man should
be fun check us out in a circle Network
channel it will be Sunday 1:00 p.m.
Eastern the Lord's a please catch us in
a live chat and then after Sunday follow
right back up here Tuesday with me
anybody you know right back right back
when I land on this on this channel you
know twitches what will he bounces and I
don't know podcast YouTube for the
flashpoint impromptu reveal live slash
reactions should be fun what you should
do just to give some of our guys an idea
I want you to do one of your intros but
do it for the but do it for like Bungie
or deej or somebody like oh yeah you
know what if you're like infamous intros
but do it for like really awesome it's
just something fun related to destiny
next week that be kind of a good do it
like full of confused like you know
buddy doing it so for it's like it's
like I'm gonna do a laugh like if I had
a Dijon yeah
did if we got Dijon I'd pass out I'll go
crazy I'll put all type of sauce on any
true oh my god you'd be like oh wait 10
minutes later etk gunslinger warlock
life there you go
it's like the best question Dodger of
all time the guy who will talk for 10
minutes and tell you nothing the media
trained extraordinaire mommy
like guys if you if you're on here and
most you guys come from my landlords
block is my house stayin away but if
you're online
kognito has some awesome interests like
literally the few times that I've been
on there I feel like I can never live up
to the introduction it's ridiculous but
awesome no no seriously every time I
listen to it it's just like I just want
to know I want to get to the intro
because like I want to see the reaction
to it cuz every time everybody's like ok
seriously how do I live up to that what
the hell like I like to get into it I
like to do my research have preached
thank you for the cowboy really
hey everybody has their thing you've got
the intros like nail band there but yeah
follow us on Twitter YouTube gaming all
that fun stuff enjoy the weekend play
something else for a little while if
you're taking a break faction rallies
will be coming because you'll be
grinding a lot of that next week and
yeah should be a fun fun crazy weekend
so follow us like us all of those good
things leave comments like the videos
subscribe to our channels you guys know
all the good stuff it helps more than
you guys actually know the likes the
subscriptions the alerts for those
notifications they help our channels the
feed the popularity all that comes from
your support so it shout out to the
tattoo man and we wanted to chat today
and absolutely on Twitter
Boyd TF Kronos man shout out to him
definitely enjoy gauging with him as
well and the yeah our peach at was
pretty cool too man good to see you guys
that was gaming you late we're watching
it this is a good one good passionate
fun one and uh blizzard beats any Sony -
slash that stinger I don't control the
big stuff in here so yeah thank you guys
kind of a chill Friday for me so I'll be
around for the weekend but yeah who's
there gonna be lit check iron Lords on
Sunday it's always a good sign you guys
can find him if you don't catch the
YouTube and you wanted to listen to a
podcast he's on all he's on like iTunes
podcast and all that stuff so I don't
throwing this on there but
I haven't gone to that yet so yeah we
get you alright guys we'll have a good
one
we'll see you soon Tuesday gonna be lit
and we out peace